le wti l indice de référence américain
s'échange ce matin encore à 125 dollars
le baril mais il était monté beaucoup
plus haut est lundi même chose pour le
brent de la mer du nord lundi européen
qui s'échange à ce moment à 129 euros
129 dollars par don le le baril alors on
va en parler avec notre consultant
partenaires de chez dorval asset
management françois-xavier shosha
bonjour le ministre russe de l'énergie a
prévenu hier que le baril de pétrole
pourrait monter à 300 dollars qu'en est
il à quoi peut-on s'attendre
le prix et puis la disponibilité 1 des
matières premières le pétrole mais aussi
gaz titane palladium nickel etc le blé
sont les principaux canaux de
transmission du choc russo ukrainien sur
l'économie mondiale la règle de base qui
est souvent retenu par les économistes
est que une hausse de 10 dollars du
baril de pétrole ça réduit à peu près de
0,1 à 0,2 pour cent la croissance plutôt
0,1 aux états unis plutôt 0 2 en europe
est évidemment si on allait aux 300
dollars que vous mentionnez ce serait un
choc évidemment considérable les
spécialistes s'attendent plutôt à ce que
si le pétrole russe venaient à manquer
plutôt à 150 à 200 dollars le baril mais
évidemment toutes ces prévisions peuvent
être facilement remise en question elles
sont très difficiles à faire
cela dit une disparition totale du
pétrole russe
dans les transactions et relativement
peu probable le pétrole russe va être
sans doute continuer à alimenter l'asie
l'inde la chine en particulier
il va y avoir aussi et même l'europe qui
n'a pas fait d'embargos il ya aussi une
diversification des approvisionnements
avec des rapprochements avec le
venezuela voir l'iran et puis le pétrole
de schiste aux états unis enfin il faut
aussi souligner que
l'impact tout à fait réelle que la
hausse des prix des matières premières
va avoir sur la croissance va aussi être
absorbée en partie par des politiques
budgétaires des plans de résilience qui
sont déjà annoncées ou qui vont être
annoncées dans les pays occidentaux
alors ce matin le ministre français de
l'économie parle d'une crise énergétique
qui est comparable au choc pétrolier de
1973 les marchés suivent évidemment cela
de très près
les les marchés suite à de très près
tout où ça joue sur l'inflation ce matin
il tente un rebond un bon rebond même le
cac40 qui gagne 3 % le dax à francfort
près de 3
7% on assiste en ce moment à une période
très volatile françois xavier
alors effectivement en fait les marchés
financiers
sont l'autre canal de transmission
possible de la crise vers l'économie
mondiale puisque évidemment une panique
financière
provoquerait un gros problème de
financement de l'économie dans tous les
pays occidentaux et encore plus dans les
pays émergents cette panique on la voit
pas en tout cas pas encore même si les
il faut quand même noter que les
différentiels de taux entre les
entreprises et les états ont beaucoup
monté
particulièrement en europe que
les bourses européennes ont perdu quand
même 20% donc il ya quand même un effet
financier il ya un effet de primes de
risque beaucoup plus élevé qu'avant même
si on peut pas parler de panique et du
coup ça rend la tâche des banques
centrales plus difficile parce qu'il
faut qu'elles surveillent non seulement
l'inflation et la croissance mais aussi
la stabilité financière donc pour
l'instant la volatilité financière dont
vous parlez encourage les banques
centrales surtout les deux grandes
banques centrales du monde la fed et la
bce à être plutôt attentive à ce qui se
passait donc attentiste aussi dans leurs
actions en tout cas moi monter les taux
que ce qu'elle avait en tête ou moins
réduire le canal du crédit ce que ce
qu'elle avait en tête ça va être
particulièrement difficile pour madame
la gare de demain puisque elle devra
montrer que elle sait manoeuvrer au
milieu d'un choc que les les banques
centrales des tests d'ailleurs c'est un
choc où il y aura plus d'inflation est
moins de croissance il va falloir un peu
choisir entre les deux priorités et donc
on va voir tout le monde va observer
comment madame lagarde va faire demain
et comment si la federal reserve va agir
la semaine prochaine merci beaucoup
françois-xavier choucha pour cet
éclairage plus qu'important